so it's on our schedule Mr Swanson we
have one activity planned
not getting killed
nope follow me just one second now right
whoa whoa whoa whoa run run run run
what's going on my ex-wife Tammy is back
yeah
no my other ex-wife Tammy Tammy won I
have accrued 228 personal days starting
right now I'm using all of them
while I'm gone you're in charge
also I keep a sizable supply of ground
chuck in my desk remove it or it will
begin to smell
Godspeed
ah jeez
one thing I promised myself when I
buried gold in my backyard was that I'd
never be a hoarder or a miser about it
hunting
No Quarters required
I thought you were serious come on now
you know I don't give a
fresh air
real weapons and honest kill
there is no substitute for the real
thing
foreign
what are you doing here
running away from my problems
come on in
okay so here's what's going on I didn't
know I tried I am supposed to announce
that I'm running for city council and I
haven't told Ben yet I know I said that
we broke up but we couldn't we're still
dating but now I have to break up with
them for real but I don't want to break
up with them because he's so cute he's
so nice if you're going to stay here
there are three rules you need to follow
one no talk about Tammy one two no talk
about Ben three no talk I didn't even
ask an ass last night what is going
on just violated rules number one and
three you lose your coffee privileges
oh you choose nope hunting fishing or
drinking
really love to shoot a gun right now
fishing it is gentlemen
Wilderness weekend is upon us
there will be no video games there will
be no internet pads this weekend you
have two parents me and mother nature
Rangers as a reward for coming on this
trip I have gotten you each two gifts go
ahead open them
foreign
sheet the most versatile object known to
man it can be used to make tents
backpacks shoes stretchers sails
tarpaulins and I suppose in the most
dire of circumstances it can be a
surface on which to make art
what's the second gift the second gift
is the Box itself you have 10 minutes to
assemble a shelter using only your two
gifts
go all right safety basics
Donna can you tell me why it's bad to
look down the barrel of your gun is that
a trick question no Donna don't please
rule number one do not point the weapon
at a person that includes your own face
Donna now every year before we go on our
first hunt we do a toast so grab a beer
to the hunt you're here and to the
hunters
the only way to defeat the Beast is to
find the Beast Within
the traditional toast is to the hunt
and it is said by me
here is our official Retreat schedule it
divides our time evenly between work and
play Come On Everybody Let's hustle
let's get to the brainstorming
great attitude Ron I just want to get
the work over as soon as possible so I
can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me
it's like yoga except I still get to
kill something
thank you
all right I call this wonderful spot you
didn't bring a tent well I don't really
go camping ever Jerry so I'm not going
to spend 150 on a tent just gonna sleep
on the floor it's called the ground when
it's outside whatever
so running for office
now I'm gonna have to find a replacement
for you I might not win
you'll win I might not run you should
what's our plan here nope I figure we
build a fire roast the fish we shot and
uh make s'mores I don't have the
material for s'mores I do I always carry
emergency s'more rations in my car
given your hunting abilities and my
chocolate Supply I figure we could stay
up here for two
three years
you know when I was 12 my brother shot
me in the pinky toe with a nail gun
granted it was a hilarious prank and we
all had a good laugh that's awful but I
avoided going to the doctor I hate
paperwork
after a few weeks the toe just kind of
fell off you only have nine toes I have
the toes I have
let's just leave it at that the point is
the doctor said if I had come in right
away they might have saved the toe
you can't run away from your problems
especially if you only have nine toes
sorry that was uncalled for
I'm Ron Swanson
and you're Leslie nope
you with me
hey there you are
thanks for meeting me here well if you'd
have held him here instead of that
conference room I would have come to
more meetings I got to tell you Leslie
establishing this National Park right
next to Pawnee is quite an
accomplishment
this is a fine piece of land you saved
thank you Ron
you want to run it
the superintendent of Bryce Canyon
retired
a transfer shuffled a few things around
the point is someone needs to take care
of this place now thought it should be
you
all right
well first of all I would be working for
the federal government your job would be
to walk around the land alone you'd live
in the same town you've always lived in
you'd work outside you'd talk to Bears
next argument Rangers
my name is Ronald Ulysses Swanson
your job and mine is to walk this land
and make sure no one harms it
if you show up on time speak honestly
and treat everyone with fairness we will
get along just fine
though hopefully not too fine as I'm not
looking for any new friends end of
speech Swansons are you prepared for
whatever lies ahead yes sir before we
proceed do any of you have any dietary
restrictions correct you do not
first outing is right now I will be
teaching you to dig a proper Trench does
that sound like something you want to do
yes sir
this will be no fun at all